ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
กอดไว้
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนหรอ
วิกเราพบกับครูพาแล้วก็คือหญิงนะคะไปแล้ว
ในวีดีโอระดับอะไรคะครูฟ้าในวีดีโอระดับ
บีกินเนอร์ค่ะไปแล้วฝากครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วัน
อะไรซะ
วันนี้วันพุธ
วันนี้วันนะคะวันพุธที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันพุธที่ ๒  ๕  ๒
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพตอะไรคะอ่ะปีพ.ศ
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะแล้วเมื่อวาน
นี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันอังคารที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันอังคารที่ 1 เดือน
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะป่าพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 3
เดือน
กุมภาพันธ์
ปีพต
2  5  6 ห้าปีหัวข้อสอ
2022 หายไปไหนคะเขาคือ 2 เนาะใส่ค่ะวัน
นี้ก็วันพุธแล้วแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้ว
คะโครงฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
11:00 น
กี่นาทีคะ
ห้าม 12 นาทีค่ะกะสามสิบสองนาทีน้องก็
เป็นเวลากลางวันใส่เป็นเวลากลางวัน
ครูฟ้ากินข้าวแล้ว
ยังไม่ได้กินเลยค่ะอ๋อยังไม่ได้กินเลยหิว
ข้าวมากๆนะคะผู้หญิงกินข้าวหรือยังคะผู้
หญิงกินข้าวแล้วค่ะกินแล้ว
อิ่มแล้วใช่ไหมอิ่มอิ่มแล้ว
คุณครูปลาร้าน้องแต่ครูฟ้ายังไม่ได้กิน
ข้าวจะยังไม่ได้กินข้าวแล้วบางคนนะคนไทย
เนี่ยตอนนี้เป็นตอนกลางวันใช่ไหม
ตอนกลางวันเนี่ยก็กินข้าวเนาะ 11:00 น
ใช่ไหมคะ 11:00 นแต่ว่า 11:00 นไปๆเที่ยง
สมัย 13:00 น 14:00 น 15:00 น 16:00 น
17:00 นก่อน
ค่าโมงส่วนใหญ่คนไทยก็ทำงานออฟฟิศเสร็จ
สมัยเสร็จก็กลับบ้านกลับ Apartment อ่า
แต่บางคนเนี่ยก็ยังไม่กลับนะ
บางคนก็ยังทำอะไรอยู่หรอผู้หญิง
ทำงานเสื้อไหมเนี่ยจะไปกินข้าอ่ะทำงานกิน
ทำงานนั่งเนี่ยบางทีก็รู้สึกออกไม่โอเค
ใส่ไม่มีแบบไม่มีออกซิเจนเนาะไม่มีไม่มี
ต้นไม้สมัยไม่มีต้นไม้อ่าบ้านละคน
มีแต่คอมพิวเตอร์
ใช่ไหมบางคนก็เลยทำงานเสร็จไม่กลับบ้านไป
สวนสาธารณะ
ไปสวนสาธารณะได้
กรุงเทพฯแน่นะคะมีสวนสาธารณะที่
คิดว่านักเรียนอาจจะเคยได้ยินแล้วก็รู้
จัก
ที่ไหนอ่ะ
คนไทยบอกว่าสวนลุมพินีนี่น้องอันนี้เป็น
ที่สวนลุมพินีนะคะนักเรียนอย่าง
สวนลุมพินีโอเคมั้ยน้องเรียนเดินหนู
ก็ได้นะยาหยีมาก
สมัยหรือว่าข้างในอันนี้เป็นข้างในสวน
ลุ่มน้ำสวนลุมเนี่ยเป็นสวนสาธารณะใช่ไหม
คะที่
ใหญ่มากๆ
สวยลุมพินีนะนักเรียนนักเรียนเคยไปไหนคะ
ครูหญิงเนี่ยเคยไปสมัยที่ลุมพินีเนี่ยอีก
เนี่ยไปครูฟ้าเคยไปไหม
เคยไปนิดหน่อยล่ะแหม
แล้วตอนครูฟ้าไปที่สวนลุมพินีนะรั้วสวน
ลุมน้องสั้นๆสั้นๆเนี่ยสวนลุมครูฟ้าไปทำ
อะไรที่สวนลุม
ตอนไปสวนลุมฯครูฟ้าไปซื้ออาหารที่
มี
แฟนสวยๆ
มีอาหารนาที่สวนลุมพินีค่ะมีอาหารทั้ง
อาหารอาหารอาหารน้องชายวัฒนเกรียนดูนะอัน
นี้เป็นถนนนะคะถนนถนนละนี้เป็นสี่เเยกใช่
ไหมอันนี้นะเป็นสีลม
สีลมอันนี้เป็นราชดำรินะคะตรงนี้นะก็คือ
สวนลุมพินีฉันไม่มีต้นไม้มี MRT สีลมหา
ตรงนี้เนี่ยข้างๆ
ตรงนี้แล้วก็ตรงนี้เนี่ยมีอาหารสมัยมี
อาหารอากูฝาก็เลยไปซื้ออาหารที่สวนลุม
ในซื้ออาหารที่สวนลุมพินีอาหารเยอะ
แล้วก็มีอาหารหลายๆอย่างไหลแบบรอ Part  I
เลยเนี๊ยต้มยำกุ้งปีส้มตำใช่ไหมค่ะมีเผ็ด
อะไร
[เพลง]
/
ไปซื้ออาหารที่สวนลุมใช่ไหมคะข้างๆเนอะไป
ซื้ออาหารที่ข้างๆใช่มั้ยข้างๆดีเนาะข้าง
ๆข้างๆสวนลุม
ไม่ได้ไปข้างในสวยกว่าฟ้าไม่ได้เข้าไป
ข้างในสวนลุม
อย่างเพราะว่าปกติเนี่ยคนไทยเนี่ยนะคะไป
สวนลุมน้องสวนลุมเนี่ยเป็นสวนสาธารณะน้อง
เวลาคนไทยเนี่ยไปสวนสาธารณะคนไทยทำอะไร
บ้างอ่ะครูฟ้าคิดว่าคนไทยทำอะไรที่สวน
สาธารณะ
ไปวิ่งค่ะส่วนลุง
เออส่วนใหญ่ก็จะไปวิ่งมาหาบ้างสิสเตหะไป
วิ่งสนามเป็นวิ่งน้องบิ้งลืมไฟฟ้า
หาอะไรนะวิ่งช้าๆใช่ไหมได้ๆวิ่งแบบสบายๆ
หรือว่าเร็วๆก็ได้นะอ่าถ้าเก่งก็วิ่งเร็ว
ๆแต่ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยวิ่งวิ่งแบบ
จ๊อกกิ้งอ่ะสมัยวิ่งช้าๆสบายๆ
ไหนไปวิ่งเงินนะครูฟ้าเคยไปวิ่งไปวิ่งนะ
ที่สวนสาธารณะไหมคะ
ครูฟ้าไม้เคยไปวิ่งที่สวนสาธารณะคะ
เคย
000 ไม่ชอบวิ่ง
ก่อน
0 ค่ะ 0% มี 0% ไปวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งที่สวน
สาธารณะ
ความไม่ชอบวิ่งไงก็เลยไม่เคยวิ่งที่สวน
สาธารณะค่ะแล้วก็มันรอๆๆ
ผู้หญิงเคยไปวิ่งที่สวนสาธารณะไหมคะช่วย
เลยค่ะครูโอ๋ไปใส่วิ่งมันร้อนใช่ไหมคุยก็
ไปวิ่งตอน
แจ๊ค 6 โมงเย็น
18:00 น
6 โมงเย็นเนี่ยร้อนนิดหน่อยนะค่ะเคยไป
วิ่งที่สวนสาธารณะครูฟ้าครูหญิงในนะคะนอก
จากไปวิ่งที่สวนสาธารณะเนี่ยผู้หญิงยัง
เคยไปทำอีกอย่างนึงด้วยที่สวนสาธารณะ
ผู้หญิงไปทำอะไรที่สวนสาธารณะ
ไปปั่นจักรยานค่ะ
นี่ทำสักกะตาลซุ้มใช่ปั่นจักรยานนะแต่
ปั่นจักรยานเนี่ยที่สวนลุมลุมพิณีเนี่ย
ไม่ได้นะคะต้องไปสวนสาธารณะใกล้ๆ JJ
Market นั้นยาย
แล้วก็
ปั๊มจักรยานได้น้องไปปั่นจักรยานที่สวน
สาธารณะ
ดีนะครูฟ้า
เย็น
รัฐบาล
ฟ้าในลูกพ่อปั่นจักรยานค่ะ
ที่นี่นะก็ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ต้องมีจักรยาน
จักรยานใช่ภูฟ้าไปที่สวนสาธารณะพระจะมี
บู๊ทแล้วก็มีจักรยานน้องครูฟ้าเนี่ยจ่าย
เงิน
ดังนั้นผู้หญิงไปนะนานแล้วอ้ะก็
40บาท
40บาทเนาะคิดว่าไม่มีลิมิตนะ 40 บาทแล้ว
ก็ปั่นจักรยานโอเค
สมัยไปปั่นจักรยานได้นะคะไปที่สวนสาธารณะ
ที่กรุงเทพเนาะปั่นจักรยานได้ใช่ไหมวิ่ง
อ่ะวิ่งได้
บางคนเนี่ยก็ไม่ชอบวิ่งไปกูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่
ชอบวิ่งไม่ชอบปั่นจักรยานบางทีก็เหนื่อย
แบบครูฟ้าเนี่ยเป็นเด็กๆใช่ไหมครูฟ้า
อายุ
24-25
อายุ 24-25 ใช่ไหมเด็กๆคะเด็กๆไทยมากๆนะ
คะเวลาไปสวนสาธารณะเนี่ยเขาจะไปนี้ค่ะคุณ
ฟ้า
ไปยังไปไปถ่ายเรือนี่ๆไทยเรียกเรือเป็ด
ไม่เห็นมั้ย
เรียเป็ดไม่ใช่พายเรือไม้ไปถีบ
ต้องถ่ายเรือนั่นแหละนะเออ
ลูกค้าเคยนะมึงก่อนต้อง
ถีบเรือเป็ดเหมือนปั่นจักรยานเนาะใช่ๆ
อย่างเนี้ยทำเหมือนปั่นจักรยานถีบเรือ
เก็บเรือปีที่ไหนคะที่นี่มันจะเป็นเรือน
แล้วมันจะเป็นเป็ดสมัยเป็ดก้าบก้าบนะต้อง
ไป 2 คนนะเรือ 1 ลำเนี่ยเห็นไหม
i  2 ตัวหนึ่งเราเนี่ยสองคนรูฟ้าเคยไป
ถีบเรือเป็ดอยู่ที่ไหนเลยกรุงเทพมั้ยไม่
เคยหีบเลอเป็นที่กรุงเทพฯคิดว่าน่าจะนิยา
ค่ะนี่ส่วนที่พัทยาคะ I หาหรือไม่งอกกู
พระอาจจะไปเที่ยวเชียงใหม่
ไปเที่ยวอะไรที่ต่างๆแล้วก็ก็ปั่นเลี้ยง
ลิงเรือเป็ด
แม่คะ
พ่อขับสนุกดีแต่ว่าอยากจีบคนเดียว
คนเดียวได้ไหมคนเดียวโอเคไหมไม่ได้น้อง
มันจะแบบมันจะไม่ Balance นะฮะมันจะต้อง
สองคนเพราะว่าจะเป็นสองคนถีบด้วยกัน
ก็เลยต้องนั่นแหละต้องถีบสองคนก็คนเดียว
สายนี้เป็นถีบเรือเป็ดที่สวนลุมณสวน
สาธารณะณสวนลุมบาทก็แพงอยู่นะ
par30 นาที 30 บาทมั้งโง้นัดนาทีละ 10
บาทเลยนะคิดว่า 30 บาทเนี่ย 30
นาทีราคา 30 บาท 30 นาทีผู้หญิงก็เคยถีบ
ที่สวนลุม 1 ครั้งน้องถีบเรือเป็ดแต่มัน
ยังมีอีกอย่างนึงครูฟ้าถ้าไม่ชอบเรือเป็ด
บางคนแรกเขาเขาก็ไปพายเรือคายัคนะที่สวน
สาธารณะได้นะไปพายเรือคายัค
อยากดูแต่ใช่ที่กรุงเทพฯได้นะที่กรุงเทพ
ก็มีคู่ค้าโอเคไหมคะถ่ายเรือคายัคไม่อ่ะ
ฟ้าเคยพายเรือคายัคนะแต่ว่ามันเป็นวงกลม
รักเออร์
ก็เป็นมันถ่ายไม่เป็นน่ะกูบอกเลยใครช่วย
เวลาร้องพายเรือเนี่ยมันต้องไปข้างหน้า
อย่างนี้จะไม่พายเรือแล้วก็ไปไปไปแต่ครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยนี้
เป็นวงกลมนะคะ
ไวไฟ
ไม่โอเคเท่าไหร่นะคะก็เลยไม่พายเรือคายัค
สมัยแต่ถ้าไม่ชอบใช่ไหมบางคนเนี่ยไม่ชอบ
ไปวิ่งเนาะไม่ชอบปันจักรยานไม่ชอบพายเรือ
ทำอะไรก็ไปได้ทำอะไรใช่ไหมพูดฟ้าเราก็บอก
ว่าไป
ปิกนิกสวยไปนั่งเล่นนั่งแบบนี้เพราะว่า
ที่สวนสาธารณะเดี๋ยวมันจะมีเก้าอี้สวยมี
เก้าอี้อย่างนี้เราก็ไปนั่งเล่นนะแล้วก็
เด็กๆปั่นจักรยาน
เห็นไหมตามเล่นคุยกับเพื่อนโอเคเพราะว่า
ที่สวนสาธารณะเนี่ยอาจารย์อากาศเย็นสมัย
ไม่ร้อนไปทำงานก็ได้นะคะเอา Notebook ไป
ทำงานใช่ไหมที่สายได้อ้าไปอ่านหนังสือสวย
มีหนังสือ Percy  Jackson  Harry  Potter
The  Lord  of  the  Rings ก็อ่าน
หนังสือได้
สบาย
สวนสาธารณะเอาอาหารไปได้ไหม
กินได้น่ากินอาหารได้นะคะอ่าก็ไปกินอาหาร
ปิ๊กหรือว่าว่าครูฟ้าทำอาหารแล้วก็ไปกิน
น้องที่สวนสาธารณะได้ไปปิกนิกได้
ใช่
โอเค
นอนที่สวนสาธารณะโอเคหรอคนเดียวไม่ได้นะ
ต้องครูฟ้าครูหญิงใช่ไหมครูเองอีกหลายๆพล
อ่ะแล้วก็ครูฟ้าตอนโป้ผู้หญิงกับครูเอ๋
ไม่นอนอันนี้โอเคทำไมอ่ะ
มึงนอนคนเดียวไม่โอเคนะคะเงินหายนะ
โทรศัพท์หายนะคะภูฟ้านอน
ก็มีคนมาแล้วก็หยิบโทรศัพท์แล้วก็วิ่งๆๆ
ไม่ได้นะคะนักเรียนไม่ได้ต้องมีเพื่อนไป
ใช่ไหมถ่ายทรายไปเยอะๆเลยก็ไปนอน
นอกจากนี้สวนสาธารณะไปทำอะไรอีกแล้วตอน
นี้ใช่ไหมคะมากๆเนี่ยก็คือบางคนเนี่ยก็ไป
ถ่ายรูปนะ
คนในไปถ่ายรูปเห็นแนะผู้หญิงคนนี้เนี่ย
เขาก็มีกล้องถ่ายรูปใช่ไหมคะไปถ่ายรูป
ถ่ายรูปต้นไม้ไปฉากว่าสวนสาธารณะเนี่ยมัน
จะมีต้นหมากเริ่มต้นไม้สมัยถ่ายรูปต้นไม้
ถ่ายรูปนกสมัยนก
นกไปถ่ายรูปได้หรือว่าคนไทย
คนไทยเนี่ย
เรียนจบใช่ไหมคะ
ถ่ายรูปครับ
[เพลง]
ถ่ายรูปคนไทยเนี่ยเวลาเรียนจบสมัยเรียน
University มหาวิทยาลัยเนี่ย bachelor
degree เสร็จแล้ว
ไหมบางคนเนี่ยก็ไป
แบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะมีชุดอ่าว
มีชุดที่เรียนจบแล้วก็ไปถ่ายรูปที่สวน
สาธารณะหน้าหรือว่าไฟฟ้า
สมัครโปรฟ้า
แต่งงาน
สแตนแตนแตนกว่าจะแต่งงานก็ถ่าย
พรีเวดดิ้งที่สวนสาธารณะโอเคสวยสมัยกีฬา
ดู
ว่า
ไป
ไปถ่ายซีรี่ย์ได้หรือว่าครูฟ้าไปถ่ายรูป
สนุกๆโอเค
มันฟ้ามีเพื่อนใช่มั้ยเพื่อนเพื่อนเพื่อน
เพื่อนๆเป็นทีมเป็นแก๊งค์แล้วครูฟ้าถ่าย
รูปก็โอเคมี
สวนสาธารณะทำอะไรได้หลายอย่างเลยลายค่ะ
อยากถ่ายเดินใช่มั้ยไปเดินเดินเดินเดิน
เล่นก็ได้ขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์เข้าไปได้ไหมคะ
ได้นะคะมอเตอร์ไซค์เบิ้ลรุ่นเนี่ยไม่ได้
ไปได้เนาะอันนี้ก็เป็นคนไทยแต่ละคนไทยไป
สวนสาธารณะทำอะไรบ้างนะคะแล้วนักเรียนใช่
มั้ยเวลานักเรียนเนี่ยไปสวนสาธารณะนัก
เรียนชอบทำอะไรแล้วก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้
นะคะใส่แล้ววันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนนะคะ
แล้วเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าเนาะบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ